[Music]
did you vote yesterday yeah this guy
voted I did I I'm proud of that I'm
excited about it I think that everyone
should vote I think there are really
only two reasons why people don't vote
in America I'll act them out okay
there's a reason number one oh [ __ ] is
that today yeah that's a lot of people
yeah there's reason number two I don't
know where it's dammit is that the same
place [ __ ] I don't know
yeah that's the second reason and that's
and they both lead to that doesn't
matter anyway you're right that's it and
it's a huge chunk of people that don't
vote I know it's ridiculous you got a
vote it's important to vote it does
matter people don't think it matters but
it matters it sure does do you know what
I mean absolutely they do look I think
honestly I think democracy works I know
I might be in the minority I'm not
cynical but I think of everyone votes I
think I think it can work and I don't
yeah I was gonna say as a group a lot of
people tend to make the right decision
if you get enough people involved that's
right and even if they don't make the
right decision that's how democracy
works it's like people used to say about
Obama he's not my president no he is
actually he's actually your president
he's everyone's president that's how it
works if you don't like it all right
next time your vote for something
different right right this is I think
most Americans are decent people I think
99% of them are I don't think this is a
good time to judge them they're angry
that worked up they want things and
they're ugly at this time of year yeah
but I think democracy works and
sometimes don't realize how it works
because you think of the anger but even
those people this is how democracy works
even those people who like two years ago
we're like gays are getting married what
the hell is happening this is against
God how why would we let gays get
married two weeks after they passed the
law in that guy state to allow gay
marriage he was saying this I guess
that's how it is now
I didn't vote for it but that's how it
is yeah people wanted it
sorry fellas no hard feelings yeah
Congrats on the nuptials yeah now are
you at all worried about Donald Trump
well I think we should all be worried
but I do think that sometimes I think
maybe there's a little bit of a reaction
I do I know people and I'm sure you guys
do who are like if Trump wins I'm
leaving the country and I'm like why
it's gonna be hilarious yeah I mean
think about it like neither party likes
him you know how government works
neither party likes him they're just
gonna hold him hostage in the Oval
Office
where he's gonna sit there with a taco
bowl wearing diapers going why can't I
make decisions on my own you're looking
forward to it well it's not if she
qualify all this with god forbid yeah
yeah both for the lady or the angry Jew
that's what I say even even if even if
that's all you know about them that's
fine that's enough
you